life has dealt me some shitty cards but
with this I'm about to play a Royal
Flush we're about to be venture
capitalist on the south side venture
capital venture capital hallway is
better because we're taking people's
money on an adventure
nice dude he's selling popcorn it's a
target but we legally loading up the car
Paco we got all right everybody settle
down
Stacey please stop popping that go bro
I'm gonna need you to either pick that
afro all the way out or pet it all the
way down I don't want to see it in the
middle okay daddy right there he is so
cute okay I got to get mines and I gotta
go get this dick okay officer go get
that dick let's do this with some tang
my name is Keisha yes I went to Kenwood
yes I know Eddie curry we used to go
together yes I have a son he is an elite
basketball player okay any paperwork you
have another side yeah you like science
[Music]
Oh
your dad's gonna get a real good job
miss gonna bring all you together in a
big fancy house
[Music]
Oh first- khakis write this down
butoh bar this out very cavalier person
beautiful
god is good somebody told me i will get
a blessing asleep
[Music]